be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so with the announcement that he'll be
added to the agents of shield cast in
season 4 what I want to do here is have
a discussion about the all-new Ghost
Rider
Robby Reyes and what I'm hoping is that
at the end of all this you'll have a
stronger understanding of his character
as well as what he's about ahead of his
appearance in the show later this fall
and so in the notes following all new
Ghost Rider number one we learned that
Robby Reyes was actually the brainchild
of the books editor mark penny Chia who
wanted to rebuild the character and take
a significant leap forward and citing
earlier changes such as transforming
Ghost Rider from a western style
character that wore a cowboy hat and
rode a horse to a biker with a flaming
skull penny Chia wanted to take the next
step in the character's evolution and
draw inspiration from his love of
classic cars and listing the services of
Phillipe Smith to flesh out the concept
of the character hoping the Smith's
background and non superhero comics
would lead to an unconventional approach
to the character Smith made the decision
to give the new Ghost Rider series a
different feel than most of the Marvel
books by choosing Los Angeles for the
setting and alongside artist trad Moore
came up with a concept designs for the
character as we know him
so Robbie way has made his debut in all
new Ghost Rider number 1 in May of 2014
written by Phillipe Smith and drawn by
trad and in addition to being a high
school student and working after school
in a garage and body shop Robbie is also
responsible for being the sole caretaker
of his handicapped younger brother named
Gabe during this time and on his way
home from work
Robbie sees his brother being tormented
by a group of teenage thugs that have
forced him at his wheelchair enraged
Robbie punches one of the gang members
in retaliation but finds himself staring
down the barrel of a pistol pointed at
his forehead by Gera the gangs leader
now while Robbie is not shot he does
suffer a beating at the hands of the
gang before they leave with Gabe's
wheelchair and so following this
Robbie's devotion to his little brother
becomes the driving force behind his
character and his desire to get Gabe out
of the current situation leads Robbie to
borrow a car from the garage where he
worked and enter into a street race with
a cash prize of $50,000 to the winner
now Wally's racing Robbie's cars pursued
by a helicopter and several other cars
and where Robbie does find himself at a
dead end and surrenders to what he
believes to be the local law enforcement
he finds out the men inside the vehicle
actually draw their guns
and kill Robbie instead and so while the
men retrieve their bags full of pink
pills from the trunk of their car and
set fire to it after they leave
Robbie seemingly gets up but we also
learned that his skull is made of metal
and it's completely engulfed in flames
in addition of this Robbie is able to
get back into the car and actually
pursues the men who murder him and while
Robbie does manage to run some of them
over most make it back to their
destination the lab of a man named dr.
Szabo whom after realizing that one of
the bag pills is missing transforms into
a monster named mr. Hyde and kills the
captain of his troops before sending the
rest to recover the missing bag now
following this Robbie wakes up the next
day believing that his death and seeming
resurrection had all been a dream
however he notices that one of his eyes
has turned orange and his face is
miraculously healed from the beating he
took at the hands of the game the
previous day in addition to bearing a
mysterious marking on his face when he
returns to work he also finds that the
car that he raced has no signs of damage
and when Robbie attempts to take the car
out that evening he's confronted by
members of the gang that serve a drug
dealer named grumpy the owner of the car
after this they start shooting but
Robbie saved once again when he
transforms into the man with a flaming
skull who fights off the thugs before
getting in the car and driving away and
so once he stops Robbie gets out of the
car and finds that he's transformed back
into his normal self but also sees a
flaming skull in the reflection of the
car where robbery begins to talk to the
skull the man tells him that he's the
spirit of a guy named Eli Morrow who's
been murdered and that he and Robbie are
now eternally bonded in addition to this
he promises to give Robbie the ability
to fight back against those who would
have wronged him the men who basically
killed him and the thugs he bullied his
brother and even his parents who
abandoned him leaving him the
responsibility of caring for his brother
in addition to this Eli goes on to
explain that not only would
Robbi be bonded if Robbie would trust
him but that both of them would also be
bonded to the car now after some
hesitation robbie agrees to trust eli
hoping to gain the power to make a
better life for himself and gabe
following this once Robbie's bonded with
Eli Eli continues to attempt to
influence him to solve his problems
through violence where Eli constantly
reinforces the belief that people are
bad and the only way to really change
the city is to burn it down and start
over eventually a gang war breaks out
between grubbies gang and mr. Hyde's
paramilitary forces who've enlisted
gueros gang as informants with grumpy
eventually taking a handful of Zappos
pills and transforming into a hulking
monster who's able to fight off Robbie
and his ghost rider formed he ultimately
finds himself ripped in two during a
fight with mr. high the next day Zappos
troops attempt to hunt down the rest of
Grumpy's gang and the school bus that
Gabe is riding in is caught up in the
crossfire as a result Robbie arrives on
the scene and begins to fight mr. Hyde
who remarked that he remembers Robbie
but his smell is different and that he's
unskilled and weak and can't possibly be
Ghost Rider and so in a state of
confusion
Robbie asks Eli what height is talking
about but Eli claims to have no idea and
so as mr. Hyde finds himself unable to
finish off Robbie he takes a handful of
pills and begins to overdose on the drug
and turn back into mr. Szabo with Zotto
neutralized Robbie leaves the scene and
we see him later confront Garrow and his
gang however in a turn of phrase from
what we'd seen earlier they tell him how
impressed they were by his victory over
high but without responding to them
Robbie knocks them unconscious and takes
bag Games wheelchair as so following the
introduction of Robbie Reyes and his
origin story going into his ongoing
series as it was written the dichotomy
between Eli and Robbie increases and
that Eli consistently urges Robbie to
take up a life of vigilantism and with
the world of people who don't deserve to
live and whose presence is a drain on
society
Robbie however is more concerned with
earning money and street races in order
to work fewer hours of the body shop so
he could spend more time with Gabe who's
showing tremendous progress in his
development at the same time mr. high
had perfected a new and improved version
of his drug in the form of
the blue pill that allowed him enhanced
abilities in addition to attempting to
distribute his drug to unite the games
of Los Angeles under his control the
following this and when Robbie hears of
low rates with a $50,000 purse says
out-of-state he competes NES successful
in winning however when his opponent
offers him the chance to go double or
nothing the next day while he takes it
his chances of winning are ruined by
mutated animals that have ingested mr.
Hyde's defective pills and attacked
Robbie and so loosing the race
Eli encourages rather you track down the
man who beat him and take back the money
he rightfully should have won and so
from here Robbie runs the man off the
road and accidentally kills him and
while he laments he's approached by
Ghost Rider Johnny Blaze now after a
brief struggle Johnny looks inside the
soul of Eli and reveals him to be a
murderer and a Satanist as well as a
former Russian mobster that had taken as
many as 52 lives and dismembered many of
his victims for use in satanic rituals
and so following this Elias caves and
eventually is able to take full control
of Robbie's body after Robbie passes out
from exhaustion now where elide goes to
Robbie's house and begins ripping up the
floorboards to find a box he had left
there while he had been alive inside is
revealed the name and address of a man
named Igor even off a mob boss that Eli
vows to take revenge on now well as is
happening Johnny Blaze continues to
pursue Eli and we learn that since he's
not committed to avenging the innocent
or milk the wicked repent that Eli
morrow although similar in appearance to
his choice of chain as a weapon is not a
true ghostwriter instead once Johnny
Blaze catches up with Eli Igor's club
the two began to fight and Johnny
subjects Eli to the penance stare which
makes him feel the pain and torment that
he caused over his previous victims and
the pain is so severe that Eli actually
leaves Robbie's body now this point
Johnny tells Robbie that Eli spirit
thrives on Robbie's anger and negative
feelings and then he gives in to those
feelings Eli will take full control once
again however unbeknownst to Robbie
Garrow had traveled to the club owned by
mr. high to apprehend even off and
overheard the entire conversation
finding out that Robbie was the ghost
rider that had beaten him up and so
following this Robbie loses control
after Garrow confronts him at school and
Eli takes over yet again however after
beating up girls gang Eli remains firmly
in control of Robbie's body during
time when his teacher mr. wake furred
comes to his home to check on him after
the fight
Eli attempts to kill him but Robbie is
able to retain enough control to stop
him
after which he punches the teacher and
instruction to never come back out of
fear that he won't be able to hold a lie
off for any measure of time and so Eli
continues to remain and Robbie's mind
constantly tempting him to give in to
his anger and step over the line to who
can continue to control over his body
and satisfy his blood lust as Robbie and
Gabe grow further apart
Eli tries to enrage Robbie by revealing
to him that he was actually Robbie's
uncle Elias and then he had pushed
Robbie's mother down the stairs when she
was pregnant with Gabe which led to his
disability now where this fails to
sufficiently enrage Robbie
Eli begins to manipulate game and
eventually take over his body as well
leaving him to finally take revenge on
even off once and for all now after this
Robbie follows them and is able to
convince Gabe to shut out Eli's
influence and reconcile with Robbie but
the reunion is short-lived went even off
pulls on a gun on Gabe and threatens to
kill him before he has a chance to pull
the trigger however Robbie kills even
oven and doing so forms a permanent bond
with Eli after which Eli vows to eat
away at Robbie's soul but Robbie strikes
a deal with him in order to satisfy
Eli's desire for blood Robbie will allow
Eli to find the most degenerate people
he can murderers rapists and torturers
people like himself and Robbie will kill
them and so we Eli accepts the deal
the two remain linked together which
actually goes into the run to the start
of secret Wars by Jonathan Hickman
now following secret Wars the Marvel
Universe was recreated as an entirely
new line of colleagues that were
launched with issue number ones in late
of 2015 while Robbie Reyes was initially
absent from this new universe he was
revealed the following year the Marvel
would be releasing a slate of new series
in the fall of 2016 including Ghost
Rider by philippe smith and artist
danila Bayreuth in november closely
coinciding with Robbie's appearance at
agents of shield during an interview
with marvel.com writer Phillipe Smith
revealed that the new series will
basically pick up right where the last
one ended and we'll also see focus on
the relationship between Robbie and gain
as well as how the agreement between
Robbie and Eli has progressed but with
that being said because there's so
little information on Ronnie Reyes at
the moment there's really not a whole
lot to offer here but he was a character
that a lot of you guys requested because
of the fact that he is going to be
showing up in agents of shield so
figured I'd do my bad
to grab what precious little information
we have and bring it to you guys with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you guys later peace
[Music]
you